Listen up asshole
That's my new neighbor.
what is his name
captain funtastic that's what I've been calling him
Such a nice day for a jog.
What's going on in his head ? What my ass doesn't look good in this  skirt.
Given the current climate
It feels inappropriate for me to comment on your Bud.
Brainden! Tight as a snare drum
You could bounce a quarter off that thing
Screw him. Today's Monday. I'm making a partner, baby. Hmhmm!
Headline news,
somebody in this room is about to be some worldwide sports management snow its partner
oh, that pass was actually to Addy.
wow... ha ha yeh!
I am so sick of this boy's club.
I  rip off your eyes and fuck the sockets
Oh! fuck your mom.
Ad agency exec. Oh no. It's my brother
Said you're gonna fuck your brother's mom.
They say that?
I don't connect with men.
I hired a psychic
Where did you find her.
Facebook! I can help you.
Why don't we have some tea.
This smells like dirt.
Oh, that's just jasmine tea
if you don't count the weed and the peyote
Okay
I Feel weird after last night.
Yeah, that's what happens when tequila meets desperation.
Stop doing that.
Are you reading my mind? Because if you can hear my inner thoughts I am super hoot...
I can hear your inner thoughts and you are super fat.
Does he mess me up.
Did you shit yourself? No
Did you shit yourself? No,
No, I have psychic powers
You can hear what I'm thinking right now.
Not you, just men.
You know, you could use this to your advantage
You'r right.
Two grands.
I'm bluffing these false
pretzels are delicious.
I'm gonna freeze my sperm ahead baby ice cubes.
Ha Ha hm hm
What the fuck ?
wow..
Nice shot
look at you
pressing all the ladies.
Whatever
Why would I waste a second owner when I got you standing right in front of me?
oh! yes.
Why are her eyes always closed. you know thats ugly.
Damn eyes open, but she look crazy as hell
wow, wow, wow...
Who are you
I hope it's okay. I borrowed your mask.
Welcome to Wakanda.
Close your mouth. Don't breathe. Don't say.
Enough.